we are at a makeshift refugee camp you  have the frontline with Isis outside the  Kurdish town of  because the fighting started it sort of  broke the ISIS stranglehold on the  villages and then it gave the people the  chance to escape  and people had been caught trying to  leave by Isis and all them were taken to  the local mosque and executed  petitioner column near Harriman Mojave -  what's now our Anna Tovar see Sharon  ossifer I didn't esta shadow Jarrah  wanted it  no discussion or little engine hot  - chaotic scene refugees have been  streaming in there for the last couple  of days clean fighting between the Iraqi  army and Isis coming back with injured  bodies and all their belongings just  seeds of chaos here as they try to  escape refining they're basically being  held there until the local authorities  can you figure out what to do with them  [Music]  you